at this Market in Zimbabwe many of the
items on offer are too expensive for a
growing number of people here and it's
likely to stay that way for some time
un say some 21 countries are facing the
combined effects of debt and high food
prices
apart from Zimbabwe Afghanistan Cameroon
Ethiopia Haiti Lebanon Somalia Sri Lanka
and Sudan are in the same situation
all of these countries governments are
in Doha for the United Nations least
developed countries conference
at the top of the agenda at their
request is the push against
International lenders to reduce the debt
burdens faced by the 46 countries
considered least developed in other
words they have less than a thousand
dollars annual income per capita
the co-author of a new report says a
system that's largely built to benefit
the global North is driving the world's
poorest countries into a vicious cycle
of rising hunger and poverty he has some
solutions
one way is surgery less they have to
build surface Reliance in their own
system instead of importing from outside
or
relying on external fertilizers you know
fertilizer coming from outside or seeds
coming from outside we have to rely on
our own soil on our own people on our
own knowledge to produce food because we
have to really really fight to improve
or to change the financial structural
system in the world
never again he argues should countries
have to choose between repaying debts
and ensuring their people are fed
but it's not clear if anyone's listening
Veronica Pedrosa Al Jazeera Doha